happy birthday Peter 20 years of
friendship can you believe it how do you
still speak to me do you remember the
first night we met
never stops being weird so weird and
they'll never stop being awkward on the
red carpet
yes Reese Witherspoon and Ashton Kutcher
are finally teaming up in the new
Netflix rom-com your place or mine but
their pictures from the recent Premiere
has had everyone talking specifically
Ashton's wife Mila Kunis yes Reese
stopped by today with Hoda and Jenna
admitting Mila called them out for their
red carpet snaps better friends with
Mila because I'd known her for a very
long time she's so professional he's the
funniest guy I mean such a goofball we
had so much fun and every time like he'd
wear a funny outfit I'd text me I'd be
like what is he wearing she even emailed
us last night she goes you guys look so
awkward on the red carpet why are you
just not anyway Mila wasn't the only one
who thought the two stars were looking
super awkward together on the red carpet
fans stick to Twitter to share their
thoughts with one saying I choose to
believe the Ashton Kutcher and Reese
Witherspoon rom-com is about to be so
spicy they needed to look like they
hated each other for the Press tour to
avoid drama meanwhile Ashton appeared on
the chicks in the office podcast where
he addressed the red carpet awkwardness
my wife called me she texted Reese and I
together and she's like guys
you gotta like you gotta like act like
you like and I'm like what's going on if
I put my arm around her and was like all
friendly with her I'd be having an
affair with it like that would the rumor
would be that I'm having an affair with
her right if I stand next to her I put
my hands in my pockets so there's no
chance that like that could be the rumor
the rumor is we don't like it yeah you
guys hate each other
Reese and I are really good friends